I don't want my young children
indoctrinated with dangerous ideas and
as time marches on I trust public
education less and less I know that you
have strong thoughts on the danger of
the devouring at Apple mother who harms
her child by protecting them and that's
certainly not what I aspire to I wonder
if in spite of your idea that kids need
to become tough and learn to slay
dragons if you have anything good to say
about the idea of homeschooling well I
don't have anything bad to say about it
I do know that the Quebec government has
recently taken moves to make it much
more difficult for people to homeschool
their children and it's not like five
years I mean 15 years ago I would have
presumed that the vast majority of
people who were homeschooling their
children were to be viewed with
skepticism initially I'm not so sure
about that anymore you know for example
I was sent a poster today someone sent
me this link that they found in a local
junior high school and one of the media
pieces that were recommended on this
poster was a movie called Hedwig and the
Angry Inch now I thought that was a
terrible movie even though I'm perfectly
capable of enjoying bizarre movies but
so it's a bizarre movie that's for sure
but I also thought it was a terrible
bitter movie terrible and bitter those
are separate a movie can be bitter and
be quite great but it was a terrible
movie and it was a bitter movie but I
can tell you one bloody thing about that
movie it's not required viewing for
twelve-year-old kids that's for sure so
I think you have increasing reason to be
skeptical of the public education system
I also looked at the Elementary Teachers
Federation of Ontario's guidelines for
education from kindergarten to grade
eight and what that is in essence and I
think I will do a video about it in the
relatively near future is a blueprint
for transforming children into social
justice warriors it basically says that
it's like you don't have to be a
conspiracy theory to read that I mean we
have social justice tribunals in on
and so the idea is well if you're going
to get your children if you're gonna get
people to what would you say favor
equity properly well then you better
start teaching them or well they're
young it's like maybe not so now you you
asked that question properly because you
say well the terrible education system
the wonderful mother homeschooling right
that's the danger it's like no because
it might not be the wonderful mother
homeschooling it might be the
pathological mother using the pathology
of the education system as a excuse to
get her talons into her children right
because that's certainly equally
possible or perhaps even more possible
because at least in the public education
system there's some necessity for
consensus so that's something that you
have to be very aware of and work to
prevent right and so I would say if
you're going to do that probably best
not to do it on your own and you need
it's like you need a board of advisers
or something like that and so maybe it
can't just be you and you have to figure
out well what what is the aim and how
are you going to manage that and what
makes you think you can do it even if
it's being done badly publicly what
makes you think you could do it better I
mean my general advice is and people
have asked me this in fact I had a
conversation with the guy who was tiling
my backyard this morning about something
his son had said to him that he was
taught at school recently which really
made the Tyler who had come from a
rather authoritarian country step back
on his heels and think I'm not so sure I
should be sending my kid to public
school anymore and maybe I shouldn't be
living in Toronto even you know but my
general advice is keep an eye on your
kids and discuss with them what they're
learning and and help equip them with
the tools to not only to articulate
their own viewpoint in response to what
they're being taught now with the
problem is you might not have the time
nor the ability to do that that's no
simple thing and increasingly if you're
unwilling to have your children
participate in what is in
Celie indoctrination and not education
thanks to in no small part to the
Ontario Institute of the studies on
education which is an institution that I
particularly despise because I think
that all it does is almost all it does
now is produce indoctrinated children
it's not an easy it's not an easily easy
problem to solve so more more power to
you wanting to put your children in a
situation where they're not being
indoctrinated but the alternative is
very very complicated and difficult so
[Applause]